the Jo Rogan Experience you really did
break Francis and gano's punch record
yeah so I don't know what the confusion
is you know I I I didn't want to a lot
of people are they doubt it just cuz
he's so big so I'm going to post it uh
we just sent it to Jamie we sent one
where you broke you went to
170 yeah 170 so you got Eddie
Hall the got he got 13
and Francis had gotten 129 we're trying
to break's record right now I had
already hit four
times
170 now the only thing that so this is
the thing that people don't understand
though is it it's the same machine I
think everybody thought it was like one
of those punching bags that are down at
the the walk right and uh you know it
it's aggravating because I pride myself
of my power I I I want to hurt you you
know what I mean like that's my
intention I'm trying to I mean we all
throw with power right but I feel like I
have a little different intention
sometimes so you know I've always prided
myself in hitting hard I've always felt
like I hit harder than everybody um now
sure I'm sure francis's punch feels
different than mine but I got speed I
got power and I walk at like 220 when
I'm at a camp so I'm not a small guy you
know I mean I'm 6'2 220 when I'm hitting
that and even then probably there I was
probably late because I was in injured
so I was probably about 212 214 when I
hit that and just to put it up I'm going
to post it whenever uh I get back home
and I'm going to post a video and I'm
going to post the picture also of me
hitting higher than that at 181 I only
have the picture but Toco Allen's coach
was there I think someone has kicked it
up to like 187 I think that's the newest
high kick which is crazy kick yeah yeah
that your your punch is that close to a
kick yeah that's pretty nuts now get it
it's a standstill object right I smash
that
thing but I I was trying to see who did
it here's Alo and Wonder Boy kicking it
there's someone just did 189 I don't
know who that is Loren Lin that's Loren
Lin yeah I think he's got the record now
Loren who used to fight in the UFC now I
guess he's with the pfl now right
because I thought he was Bellator oh
yeah Bellator is the pfl now yeah but
Loren got 189 oh Jesus he got 235 Loren
can [__] kick hard that's a super
underrated dude I always go to his fight
with Neil Magny go watch that fight
Jesus I would love to see Diego strike
oh yeah he's another one yeah yeah Jose
there's probably a quite a few guys that
can kick like that but Loren's like if
you watch him that technique is just
perfect he's perfect the way he switches
his hips the way he turns his body into
it is just maximizing it yeah I it's
really I mean some people it's weird you
know for me because a lot of people
think I have natural power and I get
annoyed with it because I've I've never
had anything natural in my life you know
everything was difficult learning it
learning Jiu-Jitsu learning how to box
you know everything was hard for me to
learn so I have a bitter chip on my
shoulder when people are like trying to
discredit it with natural power there
there is a thing though where there's a
there's like you could unlock horsepower
in a human being but you only have so
much when it comes to power there's
certain people and I think you've all
we've all seen them they just don't hit
hard for whatever reason and they look
big they can look strong and then
there's certain guys that for whatever
reason they [__] hit crazy hard and
they're not that big and a lot of it is
efficiency and fluidity and the
technique and the leverage and that's
all learned right but there's like a
certain thing to like bone struct
and just natural power my bones got to
be trash Joe cuz I've [__] having two
surgeries and I think the amount of
power that you generate I mean it's
probably a lot of it too it's probably a
corny thing to say but I was told that I
almost generate too much force for my
bone density to handle um I don't know
how true that
is